(Música)
Abran sus corazones a los increíbles regalos
de la civilización.
Si accionan un interruptor, hay luz eléctrica.
Si abren el grifo, hay agua fría y tibia
y potable.
Es un regalo que millones y millones
jamás experimentarán en el mundo.
Estos son solo algunos de los muchos regalos
a los cuales podemos abrir nuestros corazones.
Por lo tanto, deseo que abran sus corazones
a todas estas bendiciones, y que las dejen fluir a través de Uds.,
para hoy que bendigan a todos
aquellos que conozcan,
simplemente con sus ojos,
con su sonrisa,
con su roce,
o con su simple presencia.
Dejen que la gratitud se transforme
en bendición a su alrededor,
y entonces será realmente un buen día. (Música)
(Aplausos)
Louie Schwartzberg: Gracias.
Muchísimas gracias. (Aplausos)